it's a whole new Mariah's world her
billionaire ex-fiance is out while her
sexy backup dancer is definitely in
without me me has told us that actually
there is nothing going on with that
dancer but a reality show it seems to
tell a different story
well here's what's obvious Riya and
backup dancer Bryan Tanaka are totally
flirting in the new promo does have a
crush on her what I'm gonna do with him
you saw it he's not leaving that easily
let's break it down she sits on his lap
pour champagne on his abs and that's
Bryan on a safari with her and her kids
all of this apparently while Mariah was
engaged to billionaire James Packer so
here's a question are the sparks for
real or just a reality show ploy to keep
the show sexy after the engagement was
called off it's from Rock area let's go
are you the mutual affection sure looked
real this summer when we visited Mariah
in Vegas but a source close to Kerry
told ET that despite the rumors the two
are just friends so where is James
Packer in all of this well it looked as
if he may have been erased from Mariah's
world
the billionaire ex-fiance does not
appear in the new promos and here's
where it gets really interesting this
week he released a set of photos to
promote the show and out of the 22
images this is the only one which
included Packer the pic appears to have
been photoshopped to put him in the
shadows and Mariah in the spotlight so
she was so upset in the studio she threw
her diamonds against the wall so that as
many asking as Mimi taunting her ex last
night she posted this photo of herself
wearing the 35 karat engagement of
reading Packer gave her she wants to
keep it but a source close to Maria says
he wants it back and finally EV does
split left Mariah heartbroken you
wouldn't know it from this although we
do get a glimpse out of the singer in
her wedding gown
you